[Music]
[Applause]
all right so the big story has to do
with the Jets Zack rosenblat is a senior
writer for the athletic and this all
unfolded yesterday afternoon thought it
it's going to be a quiet afternoon there
Zach and then all of a sudden couple of
tweets come out and all of a sudden here
we go with Zach Wilson and the Jets and
Aaron Rogers in there as well and Robert
Salah so where do you want to start with
this of if you how about this you're
Zack Wilson what do you do
today uh if I'm Zach Wilson I probably
am addressing my teammates I would say
and and you know because especially if
they do plan on playing him and if his
teammates have this image of him that he
doesn't want to play for them and fight
for them then I imagine that probably
doesn't sit well in that locker room so
I I I would imagine he would have to
address his teammates right now okay but
Robert Salah said this isn't
true that's not what Robert Salah said
Robert Salah
said that Zack Wilson walked into his
office 30 minutes before that to say
that he wants to play that doesn't
change everything that happened before
that and I I I don't think Robert Salah
denied what happened he just didn't
address it directly is how I would say
okay what would you ask Robert Salah
today what would I ask Robert solid
today h that's a good question
um I don't know like how do you keep a
guy on the roster that doesn't want to
play I think would be the big question
and you know
obviously Zach has changed his mind um
smartly and obviously there were a lot
of factors there I they wanted they
asked Aaron Rogers to call him and and
talk to him about coming back and making
him understand that this would be a bad
look for his career if he refused to
play and and maybe that that message got
through or the report made it made it
get through but I I I think ultimately
yeah Robert solid had probably had to
sit there and decide if they were
comfortable keeping around the team if
he doesn't want to play for them who do
you think is the quarterback for the
Jets next game
my prediction would be Trevor Simeon
this week but I it wouldn't surprise me
if Zach was the number two and came into
the game or started the week after that
kind of thing how did this start like
when do you get a heads up that Zach is
telling multiple people from players
coaches staff
members like what's the Genesis of
this yeah so I I'd heard that even
before this last Falcons game over the
last week I they kind of gave him the
message of practice as if you're going
to have to play at some point like that
kind of thing and and then what I was
told and this was yesterday morning is
um they went to him about the
possibility of playing again and and
he's and he again as we reported he
expressed some reluctance about doing it
I think the offensive line thing and the
fact and the risk of injury was a factor
because I think everybody in that
building including Zach knows he's not
going to be here next year so I think
maybe there's part of it where he wants
to kind of protect himself for as he
tries to find a new job this offseason
but um yeah so I think I think it's it
starts there and they they go to him and
you know he talks about with staff
coaches teammates about how he's
reluctant and then after some Aaron
Rogers discussions and and everything
else that's transpired I think he's kind
of come to Jesus to a degree but this is
career suicide isn't
it yeah I and that's thing I mean
ultimately you know maybe he didn't
think this would get out um is probably
part of it but um ultimately if you're
not willing to play like this is kind of
the consequence that comes with that and
so now he's there's going to be more
pressure on him frankly to go out there
and perform when he is out there yeah I
just wonder like what team's going to go
yeah come on in um even as a backup
quarterback what if our team isn't that
good or what if there's you know uh
offensive line is not good are you going
to say that I mean he wants
self-preservation but he's killing his
self-preservation with this short-term
long-term so I'm I'm just trying to
understand what's making him tick now
and what what role did Aaron Rogers
playing
this yeah I I mean I think that's the
thing he's going to have to go on a
campaign to like rebuild His Image
around some other teams who I'm sure
were probably alarmed by their support
um yeah for like the Aaron Rogers side
thing like the the whole the whole story
the Jets told everybody this this season
is that they wanted Zach to sit for the
entire season uh learn from Aaron Rogers
and the plan was not to play him they
emphasized we want a red shirt in this
year like they over and over again like
we we want him to learn and sit back and
then in week one four plays into season
he's thrown back into the mix they're
able to you know fight to a four and
three record with a very good defense
and then and then he gets benched and so
it kind of like it backfired and you
know Aaron Rogers wasn't around the
building until recently so it's not like
they were spending a lot of time
together like they had planned so Zach
kind of felt like maybe he was on an
island and and at the end you know I
haven't heard this directly from him but
I imagine he probably feels like he's
being scapegoated to a degree because
he's gotten benched so many times and
their offense is struggling and they
keep saying how they don't have their
quarterback and that's why and so Zack
Fields maybe scapegoated and maybe that
was a factor in all of this but yeah you
know I think Aaron Rogers is a big
looming part of this of course and it
just kind of like the way the season
went was not the team's plan and it and
it really backfired and I think
obviously and this has been a big
discussion in New York when Aaron goes
down um they never went out and
seriously considered signing another
quarterback to fill in for him uh to
replace Zach if and when Zach struggled
and they stuck with this group Tim Bole
brought in Trevor Simeon and it it kind
of like derailed their season okay whose
decision was it to not go out and
actually get a viable backup
quarterback um I I mean I think that
that probably comes from higher up uh GM
you know maybe conversation with Robert
all I think they they thought they could
get by with a great defense and a great
running game and they could survive with
Zach kind of like they did to start out
last year when they went six and three
but it kind of fell apart quicker this
year as they started getting all these
crazy amount of injuries on the
offensive line you have guys like Alan
Lazar not really living up to their
contract the weapons outside of like
Garrett Wilson haven't really performed
and so everything kind of backfired and
it I think they would probably admit
maybe not publicly that they made a
mistake not like bringing in another
veteran oh boy good stuff Zach uh have
fun today I'm anxious to do is Zach
Wilson gonna talk to the media have you
heard anything I imagine he will this
week I don't know what day because the
starting quarterback usually talks on
Wednesday but he's not we don't think
he's the starting quarterback we don't
know right now but okay thank you Zach
thank you that's Zach rosenblat Jets
senior writer for the athletic